So the first requirement is definitely pertinent. Members of the gym shall
be able to access their training programs. It's pretty normal for members of
the gym to have a training program. And therefore, the system should allow
them to access them. Similarly for the second one. The system shall be
able to read member cards. Normally when you get into a gym
if you have a member card, you'll have to either show it to
somebody, or nowadays swipe it, and so the system should be able to
recognize the customer given the card.
The third requirement is probably not pertinent,
because I cannot think of any meaningful case in which the system
should know what is the members' commute time. The fourth requirement, personal
trainers shall be able to add clients, is also probably pertinent. Assuming
that we have personal trainers in the gym, and they should be
able to get clients, to work with the clients of the gym,
and therefore, they should be able to add them as their clients
to the system. And finally, the last requirement, the list of members
shall be stores as a linked list. This is really something about
the how, more than the what. And therefore, for what we say before
is probably not a pertinent requirement, so we're not going to mark this one.